so you actually have a musical
background I didn't know this you were a
DJ for like years when I was a kid my
cousin uh had a record label and I was a
I wanted to be a rapper so I was DJing
and I bought all these records and I
took my dad's records and I was a DJ yes
you're like a real DJ
yeah yes
we didn't even have computers back then
remember yeah this was before cell
phones I know that's now they just plug
it just plug it in and hit a button and
everybody jump around but no we had to
yeah you know we had the boards real art
forms yeah it was fun it was a lot of
fun were you what was your like DJ name
what I don't know I was The Wanderer the
DJ Wanderer now that could mean like
many things I know that's what I'm
saying it's a whole archetype of
different ways okay I like it okay
because sometimes I'll do like the old
school and when I do the new school I do
hip-hop I'll do funk I'll do uh oh you
like a wide variety wandered through the
crates yeah I like that yeah see what
I'm saying I thought about this I was
thinking about the song The Wanderer no
no no no
yeah see and I thought that was a
different vibe that name yeah no no no
yeah I'm like LL Cool J with the Beatles
yeah that's cool crazy crazy
I love that I'm a big fan of not
limiting yourself to one genre I agree I
agree I agree there's a lot of influence
by everything I feel like everything but
if you can get like funny story when I
was in high school uh Michael McDonald
was doing a show in North Carolina so I
was like oh man that dude he remember
the Doobie Brothers yeah so me and my
roommate go to the show and this old
white dude comes out he's like
I was like man it's a cover bear he goes
no that's Michael McDonald oh my God you
didn't know he was I thought they were
the Doobie Brothers
not the Doobie Brothers oh my God that's
incredible
mind blown it was very hurtful but were
you kind of like at the same time like
this dude is killing it to this day all
I want to do is do a song with him oh my
God he's got an incredible voice he's
amazing but I love that though video did
Kill the Radio Star because it's like
you just listened instead of something
his voice has so much Soul yeah and who
don't like the Doobie Brothers like you
put some Run DMC in the Doobie Brothers
yeah
you know what I'm saying
[Music]
foreign
yeah
I'm going
[Music]